I don't think our limit as in brilliant
engineers although obviously we need to
invest in having lots of lows but is
much more in two things it's in money
absolutely but it's also an attention
span we have a few things that we focus
on and if those are the things that are
on the top of the news hour or on the
front page of New York Times it means
other things go further down or even
slip off the pages entirely so we need
to ask ourselves what is it we should be
discussing and how should we be tackling
those problems that is what are the most
effective solutions to those problems
I helped organize something called the
Copenhagen consensus where we asked some
of the world's top economist across all
areas to identify the best investments
for Humanity they told us that the top
priorities we're investing in
micronutrients in free trade in
immunization and agricultural research
and development now for every individual
company or network of course they'll
have to judge what where we best where
do we already have information and
resources to deploy but hopefully they
would deploy them in some of these best
areas some of the best solutions and not
just in some of the solutions that sound
good that give good PR but ultimately
end up spending large sums of money
doing fairly little good
getting two paths of sustainability
inevitably will have to be mostly top
down I know it feels bad because we'd
all love to be able to be part of that
solution but I think the best example
was a couple years ago the BBC asked one
of their top reporters to be ethical man
for a year we was going to cut carbon
emissions by insulating his house he
sold his car he stopped going on foreign
vacations they did all the stuff that
you had to do by the end of the year
they did the tally and it turned out
that he had managed going far beyond
what most people would want to do to cut
his individual consumption by twenty
percent it underscores the fact that you
can do a little but the big part is
going to come from societal changes that
is I live in a country where we don't we
have lots of public transport so I don't
have to have a car I never owned a car I
just have a bicycle but you can only do
that if there's lots of public transport
and likewise that you have the
breakthrough in technology so you have
cheap efficient and zero or low carbon
energy sources we need unfortunately the
top down most